now I've put these two on the board I'm
lucky to have them in today's let's roll
because these two so far are quite
special each of these we use as a launch
pad to develop new concepts new ideas
new techniques to solving the questions
we already have encountered before from
our first one Terry - be it unlock the
ability to do something in court in
Georgia everyone was fine in with the
angle between if the angle really
divides right angle between two lines
another we started if you manage this is
a different exercise with sine and
cosine and identity we sort had this
nice neat application right in the same
way over cases mm like this exam in 210
we notice that a double angle identity
from one perspective it is our hulk egg
widen see from the other perspective
so what technique did we do up yesterday
to do this we call the team results
right do you recognize you've got your
two t on one minus T squared then out of
that you make a triangle you get your
sines and cosines all in terms of teeth
now you might look at this and you might
be well what can getting all the action
what happened to all the size and cosine
filled spaces those identity where are
there applications that's what today's
lesson is about answering so I want to
give as let's concretely able to the new
women
let's just consider say or what the SIP
was what I could be gone Green Grove
City sign that's what we started let's
consider sign other company I want what
it's nice and simple so I'm going to say
I learned X plus 30 degrees figure is a
nice being able that have give us an
exact value let's see what happened as
we unpack with it
do you remember your identity for sine
of a puppy could you quit you sign or
you wanna fall in love you want well
neither both could give the same thing
right so sorry a cos B plus cos a Simon
okay so let's write that yet either
didn't that can be sine X cos very like
a bus content sign so I keep my angles
in order so I don't get to compute okay
the wonderful thing about this is a lot
of this we don't we can evaluate cos 30
of course is site that is a half which
makes the other one magic whatever to
write whatever 3 is 10 sickly please
work on them root 3 all to sine X is a
number so I put up front like a
coefficient sighs Eddie comes afterwards
that's a lot so far so good
I haven't done anything drank just
evaluated himself remember what I
started you okay I'm going to do one
more thing just to simplify things out a
teeny bit I notice that I've got these
two fractions on the right-hand side
they're both had the same denominator so
I'm just going to multiply the whole
thing through by 2 and just make it a
team
okay now I want us to pause and
contemplate this law which is
alphabetical
we can look at this last line that we've
just written to the sine of X 30 degrees
equals that'd be over there right when
you look at this it's true we've just
proven it using music results that we've
seen before but what does it mean on the
right hand side you've got two trig
functions and you've added them together
okay on the left hand side
currently you've got something which is
completely identical it says this does
look obviously to me the same as this
always saying is you can take two trig
functions combine them and you get one
trig function at the other end two
different two ways
how's it different this two threes are
what difference does that make
that's an effort to difference isn't it
right what about the 30 degrees what
does that change then our function
yeah that's the fade that's a horizontal
shift isn't it okay now this is not
actually incentive which is why I want
to find convince you on what we're
actually looking at our wine so don't
worry too much about the left-hand side
equations that's just my working yarn
you've got your two function check up
and written down right your root three
sine X and your cot X okay let me show
you what they look like
cos x were previously with that I just
want from naught to 360
before I plot it on there what do you
think what you visualize about root
three sine X it up sine X looks like you
got the shape of your head what effect
is that root three hand at the front
it's a it's stretched it out we treat
about one point seven okay
so therefore where's all point seven on
here somewhere around
yeah ish right so our you side curve is
not going to go this far like this one
it's going to go further
do you agree okay let's put it on
doesn't match so far so good
now what we've said on the right-hand
side of our equation which you have
energy that I just covered it add these
together and the purple line and the red
line what would they look like I will
show you in a second but think in your
mind what do you predict will happen
what is this new combined function going
to do what's really going to go so for
instance I know some places it has to
pass through right when I add these
together I have to go to here do you see
one why does the sub of these two
functions have to go through this
particular point there because yeah now
here's a couple line is 0 and this one
is 1 0 plus 1 is 1 in the same way if
you shuffle over a little bit here this
is 0 and this is root 3 right that's
what we said with the new input C so 0
plus root 3 is retreat and you can keep
on going you can find this series of
points that you go through here's what
happens when you get all of the points
ok have a look
do you see those two points that I
mentioned before here and here we pass
through there right from getting freaky
deaky it goes up a bit down why did it
do that what's going on how would you
describe them all start going down this
that's nuts going up so which one is we
it's like a tug-of-war between top of
the red which one wins at that first
little spot there
then a purple one the same wins for two
reasons can you see why firstly it's a
stretched-out this way that means the
whole thing is steeper here right
secondly is it this is rising faster
than this is dropping you see that like
this sort of style it's off nice and
slowly
this goes skyrocketing immediately right
it comes up has to come back down to go
to this point we identified before and
then you get the rest of the shape okay
now let me get rid of all of those
construction one yeah so this is what we
say is the sum of those two lines
that's the right-hand side of your
equation now have a look at the
left-hand side 2 sine of X plus 30 is 2
sine X do you see why not to say X we've
a root 3 sine X be further order them
right so it's still here and just
stretched up you can think it's good up
to to 130 degrees I'm going to do a
phase shift what direction are you going
go to the left right watch here we go
there she is all the way to 30 degrees
so what I conclusion from this is is
that if you add two trig functions that
sort of wave around like this what you
get is a nutrient function with a
different amplitude and a different
order imitates face very good okay so
Paigey what you change my revered a
special name becomes so important
because we'll color because it's an
angle that's included within another egg
it's like a sort of subset of the whole
X plus 30 the finish a little bit you
get to relate things it's often called
it's chiefly calling our course the
auxilary angle auxilary that's read word
aux il I add art and wine you're
sometimes to also describe as this
service is really they're afraid to the
same idea just from two different angles
ironically auxilary means you've got
something in the add a little bit on so
scenery means you've got a beating in
there's one small partner right like
you've got a company and then you've got
here subsidiaries right they're all part
of the whole so under hanging over a
corpse is auxiliary angle you can see it
just like we got say the T results out
of this particular extension here this
idea of the ordinary angle comes out of
this regular saying expansion and we're
going to see one for the cosine
extensions as well in this case we
started from knowing everything we know
this angle is you can very easily work
out what is not there is just by
multiplying through okay but the
questions you will be given go in the
opposite direction they all say okay
here's a figure a fiower can you find
out where it came from
can you find out whatever to it is and
what auxiliary angle has been phase
shifted okay so I'll give you these are